i remember it it's so weird seeing
seeing like for example chris pratt i
remember when everyone [ __ ] loved
chris brown he was like he was like the
golden child yeah
do you mean now
no no no
then suddenly and suddenly people just
started hating him i can't remember what
set it off i didn't even know why
it might have been the i remember he did
like a lot of christian remarks a lot of
people like we're not like happy about
that yeah oh okay i guess i missed that
arc of christmas i i i missed that luck
i just like one day i woke up and it was
like it was cool to like chris pratt and
then i woke up on another year and
everyone was suddenly here now it's cool
to like chris pratt again he's getting
every right i could be mistaken on this
i know that a lot of people got annoyed
at him uh around the time of like i
think when um
james gunn got fired from yes yes and
like everyone from guys in the galaxy
like try to like uh like well like
openly like supporting you know james
gone yeah i think i think chris pratt
didn't really do anything and that like
kind of rubbed you the wrong way or he
gave some vague christian-esque
statement that people didn't really like
right yeah i know that was around the
time when i first started seeing staff
people like didn't like chris pratt yeah
but you know i mean it's it's all you
know the internet's like that no you
can't stop hearing about chris pratt
because not only now is he married
but he's also garfield as well i can't
believe bro is he garfield he's voicing
garfield wait what yeah when did this
get announced today this morning
so like so like
the real mvp here chris is asian is like
[ __ ] oh yeah who the [ __ ] is that
asian boy this man is insane like you
need a raise oh this asian man he better
keep him on lock man this agent
just like your agent just walked in it
was like oh by the way you're gonna be
voicing mario and garfield next up next
up you'll see it tomorrow he's voicing
groove from despicable me he's taking
over steve carrell move aside you should
notice markzware anyway
my god
yeah like this morning especially on
twitter i was like
and also did you hear as well that uh
they're making so you know how seth
rogen is playing as donkey kong yeah
yeah donkey kong is getting his own
movie as well that's been coming seth
rogen
[ __ ] off yeah that was confirmed as well
[ __ ] off your life
unfortunately this is it was the weird
timeline i woke up to this morning
i'm like seth rogen dog killings getting
his own movie and chris pratt is
garfield what's going on with these
movies this is like the proof that we
live in a parallel universe like like
this is we've like from somehow like
we've jumped timelines and we've not
realized that we've jumped timelines do
you want the mario movie to be good
no no no no why not
actually i got to define good to find
good yeah
i wanted to like legitimately be a
critically successful would you think
the sonic movie was good
i actually like the scene i still
actually i like the song
i feel like you should go into like that
kind of rail okay where it's like
critically not nothing ever really yeah
yeah i
yeah
yeah what do i want it to be i just
don't know what to think about it i
guess i just can't put my you know how
like
when you hear the sonic movie and it's
like you can kind of figure out all
right i can kind of understand where
they would go with this cast and these
characters right that makes sense yeah
with the mario thing that they've
announced so far i think the reason why
everyone's freaking out is because i was
like what the [ __ ] is this movie like
what what are they doing actually what
actually is this movie goes against what
we just said where where we said
celebrities can't sell a movie they
[ __ ] sold me on this they saw me on
the mario you sold me
by like i'm like there is no way this
can be a movie like an actual thing
because what's so surreal about the
mario movie is that it's a [ __ ] meme
it is it is it is a [ __ ] post that got
made into reality right how is your
donkey kong as seth rogen going to
contribute to this plot i don't
understand because donkey kong rarely
contributes to any [ __ ] thing in
mario he's kind of just chilling out
the one i'm personally excited for is uh
keegan yeah
how is that gonna come into this how are
they gonna introduce keegan as toad how
does that happen in the movie i'm
thinking i'm sitting here and i i hope i
hope this age is poorly or something
yeah i'm so confused and like even now
like and they're like and then the real
mario voice actors gonna cameo how how
is that going to happen yeah that's what
is he just going to say it's a me mario
and mario is is like [ __ ] you mario
he's not for me
it's going to be like no it's so me or
mario and like they have this weird
[ __ ] rush hour 3s stupid thing like
is that what's gonna happen i don't know
like the entire thing could be like a
new grounds parody animation from like
12 like 2010 or something you know like
an oni ng yeah yeah right
except it's a [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
reality
illumination as well which is also like
the [ __ ] like i don't i don't know what
an illumination done despicable me
oh okay and that kind of those kind of
movies did they make the uh uh emoji
movie as well no that was sony okay yeah
okay so
mark
well they had like into the spider verse
and they were like counter back track
yeah i think it's different from
different studios and stuff yeah i mean
i i think i think that was a different
studio and into the spider verse it's
kind of just its own anomaly you know
because there's there's no other
animated movie i think that it's just
like into the spider verse because no
such a unique still haven't watched it
and i haven't watched it so here's the
thing right i really really really want
to watch it in the cinema and i just
didn't and then now i really want to
watch it but i'm like [ __ ] it we'll just
do a dislike
i'll find a really rich friend and i'll
be like can i go to your home cinema and
can we watch into the spider verse
because i've been like holding off on it
like can we do that i don't have any
friends with a movie theater thing maybe
face clowns like invite me out i'll make
one the trash tastes moving
theater let's move let's move the trash
taste studio to like arkansas or
something i bet like we could get like a
big plot of land there yeah probably
make our own theater arkansas yeah then
we can get a theater there goes one
fans what are you saying yeah one thing
i'm so jealous whenever i see americans
set up their studios or their house it's
just like they've got so much [ __ ]
space well yeah if we if we paid the
amount we're paying for the studio in
america we'd have like quadruple space
because like
like like
even even in like living in england as
well we don't get space in england as
well you know like our houses our houses
compared to americans are like [ __ ]
chinese they are bigger than japan it's
like where i put japan uk is 20 bigger
and then eighty percent well would you
say japan or tokyo because this is two
two different things even outside of you
know you you'll go to the countryside in
japan right and you'll look you'll see
these like giant sprawling fields you'll
see four tiny houses just right next to
each other they don't want any privacy
they decided [ __ ] privacy they're like
the rice fields need more room yeah
because that's what the countryside is
it's like yeah it's like 90 rice fields
but with the amount we're paying for
this studio if we were like way outside
of the church we'd probably get like at
least double triple some of those houses
they're giving them away for free yeah
yeah like 100 bucks a month yeah exactly
i mean like the housing market in japan
is like not the most healthiest thing in
the world i mean that's what happens
when you have a declining population
right yeah
yeah so so people are literally giving
away houses in some places it's
interesting because japan's government
is just like yeah it's a problem and
then i was like we're gonna do japan's
like yeah it's a problem
that's a lot of social issues in japan
actually
no they say no they they go oh it's a
problem what are you gonna do about it
like we'll make the old people live
longer yeah basically basically up the
healthcare
like their kids will stay on the
countryside right yeah right people want
to stay in the countryside will he have
a job i don't know it's really
interesting because
it's one of those problems that like
where it's you can't you can't have a
platform to campaign on being like yeah
i'll fix the problems that's going to
come in 30 years yeah
which is all politics i guess really
yeah